you
this morning people from around the
country are expected to gather in
Hampton Virginia to commemorate a
pivotal moment in American history this
month marks 400 years since the first
documented enslaved Africans arrived in
English North America the weekend events
kick off at the Tucker family cemetery
believed to be the burial place of some
of the descendants of the first enslaved
Africans to come here CBS this morning
national correspondent
Jericka Duncan visited that cemetery and
the Tucker family
Jericka how unique is their story very
unique Anthony it is rare for African
American families in this country to be
able to trace their lineage back to 1619
well the Tucker family believes it has
its family cemetery is ground zero for
where life ended but as we learned it is
also where the story begins
tucked beneath the trees in a quiet
neighborhood in Hampton Virginia is a
piece of American history that is rarely
seen or told like this so we had a
ground-penetrating radar
done and it went down six feet and what
did you find we found over a hundred and
four unmarked graves those unmarked
graves according to the Tucker family
are likely the remains of their
relatives who were among the first
enslaved Africans to arrive in English
North America in 1619 colonists John
Rolfe famously recorded the arrival of
twenty and odd Negroes who were captured
from Angola Africa and brought to the
shores of the Old Point Comfort Virginia
most of it is oral history that takes us
back that far
carolita Jones cope says that history
connects their family to Captain William
Tucker whose plantation was a
quarter-mile from where the Tucker
family cemetery lies today
Captain William Tucker was the commander
of Point Comfort and he kept two of
those servants Anthony and Isabella in
1624 it lists that Antony and Isabella
had a child William and that he was born
and baptized that was the start of our
family
legacy here in Virginia when you look at
this history that your family has been
able to preserve what is the
significance of knowing where you came
from and having the pictures having the
genealogy well one thing some
nice-looking family and and to look at
the way that they dress they walk with
the heads up you know with pride dignity
there were smart people they were strong
people they were hard-working people and
that just gives me so much pride knowing
that that's stock that I come from
uncovering their past has meant a lot to
this family why did the connections
matter what does it give you a sense of
knowing where you came from to now know
that my African ancestry started so long
ago and they survived like they
struggled and I can't imagine the
conditions that they lived in when they
were here but to know that we are still
here and surviving is just makes me so
proud because now we are trying to tell
our children this story and we want each
generation to keep this story going so
this is what we're doing with these
pictures are because this is our family
we face many challenges as people of
color African Americans so it helps
strengthens strengthen the next
generation moving forward to know
whether our ancestors have gone through
and did this family says tracing their
roots is not just a history lesson for
themselves but a cultural lesson that
will resonate worldwide when you look at
some of the debates that are happening
in this country today around race
relations around immigrants how does
this play into that bigger narrative I'm
sorry it's still a problem
that it's the the condition that we're
living under now and then we're still
trying to justify our existence here
because we we built this country we
helped to make it the Tucker family will
be featured in a new exhibit honoring
the first Africans landing at Point
Comfort the site was later renamed Fort
Monroe so there are over a hundred
crosses here at the cemetery yes which
represents unmarked graves that we were
able to identify doing the
ground-penetrating radar
so you had someone come here to find
potential bodies that you didn't know
we're here exactly when I started off I
I was just a young man who was looking
at this space as a very special space
and I just didn't think the nation would
pay attention Terry Brown is
Superintendent of Fort Monroe why do you
think it's finally getting attention
well I think slavery and race is a very
difficult subject for this nation but I
want to remind the entire nation that a
great country remembers its history and
it embraces all the complexities of it
what do you think that does for the
young people today when they know their
history and they're proud of it there's
nothing like knowing where you came from
there's nothing like it and for many
African Americans is very hard to go
beyond you know the civil rights
movement it's a very sad story in a lot
of ways but I'm here to tell everyone
that those Africans that unloaded here
in 1619 they were scientists they were
lawyers doctors they were not just
simply slaves they were human beings for
the Tucker family connecting back to
where they came from means embracing
where they are today we are not going
anyplace
we are here this this is where we belong
because our people helped to make
America what it is regardless of whether
they try to push us out on tell you to
go back home or whatever it is we are
home we are home
we are here efforts to commemorate 400
years of african-american history have
been embraced by both the Obama and
Trump administrations President Obama
named Fort Monroe a national monument in
2011 recognizing this landmarks role in
American history and last year President
Trump signed a law establishing a 15
member Commission to plan develop and
carry out programs highlighting the
contributions of African Americans in
this country become interested when you
were there were there other people
visiting or only the Tucker family well
this is an area for those who are
visiting for that reason they know to go
to the cemetery it's a 2.2 acres and it
is just so rare to have a family that
has held on to this history to be able
to go and find out that there were more
bodies than they expected and shout out
to Tony Furlow and Dexter Lyon who were
the sound and photographers they did an
outstanding job at that sign there that
said first Africans in Virginia looked a
little lonely and yeah it could use some
improving though people don't know about
the significance it seems like I don't
think so you know I'm actually planning
a family reunion this year in Hampton
Virginia is a place that I'm looking at
because there is so much rich history
there and you wouldn't know that I don't
think unless you you know are educating
yourself and a lot of people don't think
about the 1619 as a start yes I think
commemorating this year is very
important so I love what Terry Brown at
Fort Monroe said that a great country
rim remembers its history and it
embraces the complexities of it that's
right it is completely we have to learn
from the bad stuff but also celebrate
what's good this is such an incredible
story for this family to be able to
trace its roots so far back before most
people got to this country tell us a
little bit about the story of how those
Africans came to Virginia on a ship that
was actually bound for another color I
mean it was pirated and then it sort of
ends up here at Point Comfort which is
now Point Monroe and there's so many
rich stories there but again this family
was so gracious to share their pictures
their documents and hopefully others
will be encouraged to look up their
history and maybe give Hampton Virginia
some love
[Laughter]
you should do your family reunion there
I think the McQuaid's awkward side you
guys would get it alright look out for
that speaker thank you very much